cómo es posible que se hable de esta
cantidad de denuncias y solo se conozcan
los casos cuando un programa de noticias
habla de ellos
Hola buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación claro Hay que reconocer que
en este caso nos enfrentamos a múltiples
factores de vulnerabilidad porque
hablamos tanto de niñas como de
indígenas y en estos casos Pues el
acceso a la justicia
enfrenta barreras diferenciales así que
pues por esta razón si bien usualmente
hay barreras para acceder a la justicia
a las niñas y las niñas indígenas
enfrentan barreras adicionales
Aunque estemos una investigación que
viene del año pasado el fiscal Francisco
Barbosa solo atinó a decir sin
fundamento que era falso en caso de
violación efectuado por un militar
estadounidense y el icbf sigue sin dar
respuesta Cuál es la realidad de la
explotación sexual en guaviare
claro bueno por un lado estamos ante una
situación de su registro de casos
se sabe que las comunidades indígenas y
especialmente las niñas y las mujeres
enfrentan condiciones históricas y
estructurales de desigualdad de
discriminación de pobreza además de
inseguridad alimentaria y de violencias
es decir en términos generales no hay
una garantía de derechos y esto supone
riesgos diferenciales las niñas son
Víctimas de violencia sexuales
y además pues no pueden denunciar
usualmente las denuncias se adelantan
por personas mayores
y frente a esta situación cuál es la
respuesta del actuar del Estado las
denuncias de violencia sexual en contra
de niñas en el guaviare incluyen a
miembros de la fuerza pública que han
sido señalados como presuntos agresor en
este sentido la presencia de militares
supone en lugar de un factor protector
un riesgo para las niñas los niños y las
mujeres del departamento
bueno justamente las medidas anunciadas
por el presidente Gustavo Petro incluyen
dos unidades especiales para atender a
la población indígena y otra
especializada en violencia de género al
tiempo que se aumenta la presencia de la
policía en la zona esto es suficiente o
de alguna manera puede ser
contraproducente
no en realidad es contraproducente lo
que nosotras hemos señalado hemos venido
señalando Es que de hecho la
militarización de la vida
supone riesgos para la vida de las niñas
y las mujeres en El séptimo informe de
seguimiento a los anexos del auto cero
noventa y dos cero cero nueve se
identificó que del total de mujeres y
niñas indígenas que hacen parte de estos
casos y que han sido Víctimas de
violencia sexuales el 75% tiene como
perpetuadores a miembros del ejército y
de la armada así que por eso pues
nuestra apuesta es por una seguridad
feminista
en la cual pues las medidas deben
dirigirse a una progresiva
desmilitarización de estos territorios y
a que el estado haga otro tipo de
presencia con otras instituciones pues
Por supuesto que aseguren que se
transformen las condiciones de vida para
que las mujeres y las niñas no se vean
ante estos riesgos